on l'évoquait plus tôt il ya une
multiplication d'applications pour
téléphones intelligents qui permettent
l'anonymat sur le web des applications
qui sont montrés du doigt comme un
danger potentiel qui guette les
adolescents en ligne alors à quel point
faut-il s'en inquiéter
bonsoir matthews aus et un mode de
communication qui est extrêmement
populaire auprès des jeunes mais
certaines applications cause problème à
cause de l'anonymat
j'aime beaucoup parce que la plupart de
ces applications là en fait permettre
une navigation de manière anonyme on a
qu'à penser par exemple à l'ouest after
aphteuse secours et aux cycliques aux
états unis récemment qu'ils étaient il
ya des cas d'agressions sexuelles des
professeurs qui donc s'approprier des
photos d'étudiants hillier quillacq
également une application qui permet de
géolocaliser des conversations imaginer
le petit papier le qui circulent entre
les bus roulent à l'école jadis mais là
c'est la version en ligne donc on peut
avec ce lancer des rumeurs carrément
dingue qui se répandent de manière
anonyme alors on peut tout dans une
classe une telle couché avec intel et là
toute l'école de 6 en l'espace de
quelques secondes le mois dernier ottawa
ça même été lié à des codes de
déclenchement des alarmes d'incendié les
étudiants ça change pas sauf que les
outils qu'ils utilisent maintenant sont
beaucoup le décuple leur puissance
depuis qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
comment est ce qu'on peut se prémunir
contre ces abus là il n'y a pas de
recette magique ans c'est à dire qu'on
peut pas empêcher les ados de
télécharger ses applications là c'est
impossible
des écoles peuvent les bannir sur leur
réseau sans fil mais les étudiants vont
y accéder par l'autre la 3g fait une
bonne vieille recette d'éducation les
parents doivent être au fait de ces
applications langues sont utilisées par
leurs enfants les écoles aussi doivent
faire de l'éducation à ça parce
qu'évidemment la nuisance qui peut être
générée par ce elle est décuplé par
rapport à ce qu'on pouvait faire
il ya quelques années bref l'éducation
c'est la clé mais l'engouement autour de
ces applications de messagerie c'est
énorme quoi on n'arrêtera pas ça
il ya deux ans facebook à acheter une
application de messagerie whatsapp pour
tenez vous bien 20 milliards de dollars
ces lois de cet employé 50 employés à ce
moment-là tout s'envole vers les
applications de messagerie à un tel
point certains disent que l'application
messenger qui est aussi détenu par
facebook pourrait détrôner facebook on
s'en va de plus en plus dans une
relation en ligne via par le truchement
de ses applications là des photos qu'ils
se détruisent en quelques secondes mais
dont on peut garder des captures d'écran
il ya beaucoup de sexting aussi avec
avec snapshot et ça a créé beaucoup de
problèmes et il faut comprendre que
c'est pourquoi c'est populaire parce
qu'on venait dans l'instantané on est
dans le partage à partir de petites
photos ça ça vaut rester mais il va
falloir apprendre à vivre avec parce que
l'anonymat amène aussi son lot de gros
problèmes parce que tout le monde est là
dessus et pas nécessairement les gens
les plus recommandables
ouais donc pour le meilleur et pour le
pire merci beaucoup et inclusive